fort des chiffres des lettres ce soir
comme d'habitude depuis quatre semaines
jean-claude ça va dans ce très bon
restaurant super influent patron et un
nouveau patrick briffa commence tout de
suite par jean-claude l'ailette hockey
consonne voyelle a donc là c'est à moi
j'ai vu une émission une activité qui va
partir ce soir ça a changé
on était là s elle se voyait voyait
loyer libre au saut un soap normes
acceptables croyait alors plus consonnes
et voyelles au consonne voyelle voyelles
e et consorts bon cela sous l'eau y est
bien le temps est dépassé jean-claude eh
bien voyez max se poser à oui nous nous
as un passé avec lui
ces cd parce que ça veut dire se noyer
marc écoutez je trouve que vous
présentez votre invité le oui volontiers
je vous présente jénine des bons joueurs
gênés vous venez de jeunes et deviennent
donc cette lettre vous avez vos enfants
oui jamais de imputable à la faute et
vous n'avez pas le ferait que si j'ai le
trac mais vous m'avez dit que vous
tiendrez la mode on y va maintenant
c'est toujours bien sûr des lettres
c'est le chant toujours de simple
annonce alors chacun sont apparus la
touche soir sachant des aloses et
concerne cap conseil w concerne 7
concepts et consorts x
consoles et consoles et le temps est
dépassé alors jean claude conte et de 4
à 5,5 m
jeanine moi j'avais trouvé gerloff ski
ça veut dire sous voyez en quoi le net
j'avais crise plus mais par courriel
alors de soudoyer actions de celui qui
soudoient connaissent pas et je perds
murner une référence historique au 12e
siècle sous napoléon 2 et 10 ans ou
doyer le seigneur partout et maintenant
c'est au tour des chiffres mauvais une
sélection des clichés vichy toujours dit
si bien sûr c'est le tour de l'aude
première 1er 2e 3e 4e
le première et deuxième
voilà 0 0 c'est bon 021 tu veux pas me
dire ou es honnête
3 le demande une seconde le comté jean
claude deux mois j'ai trouvé trois oui
alors je vous écoute alors 0 puissance
00 puissance égale 1-1 va bien - 0 - 0
régale toujours 1 - 0 puissance 0 1 0
c'est à dire à moins égale zéro de plus
un égale heures oui c'est bien il y
avait plus simple à deux plus un égale à
patrice pour soudoyer une vie également
sous le g ou sous payés sarkozy a laissé
traîner l'être ce soir se termine sur la
victoire d'un candidat très sympathique
mais je vous dis la maison ce serait oui
mais vous avez même droit au piano mais
les canaux la la c'est pour le père dans
les cabinets à partir ce soir